Should I be taking BAM also, so for those that don't know because I don't recommend BAM a lot for cancer patients, BAM is our
powder supplement that we make that's called that we name BAM because I named it for brain anti-inflammatory mix, but it's actually
Not just for brain though. It does have a literal root end of which is good for the brain
But the rest of the things are just anti-inflammatory things
Which is good for your whole body. So can a cancer patient take BAM? Oh, absolutely. Yes, so there's nothing in there that a cancer patient should take
So yes, you can take that as well
So don't that doesn't mean that everybody listen to this is like, oh, I want BAM too. Welcome. I don't have BAM. Let me get BAM
Where do I get BAM? What's that? No, so but this person has that for their spousal they
They certainly can add that to their mix of sweat
so
Scott some good anti-inflammatory things in it in a mix at that time when I created that really wasn't anything on the market and
You know, that was 15 20 years ago that I developed that
So we just made it ourselves so
We just never stopped so